-Senate Republicans,
joined by Democrat Joe Manchin,
blocked a bill called the
Women's Health Protection Act
that would codify abortion
rights at the Federal level.
Also, we found out yesterday
that when he was president,
Donald Trump asked his advisers
if China had a hurricane gun
that it was using
against the United States.
Are those two things related?
I guess you'll have to stay
tuned to find out.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Every time you think
you're heard the dumbest thing
Donald Trump said
or did as president,
he somehow finds
a way to shock you.
I didn't even know I still had
the capacity
to be shocked by Trump.
It's like how, even after seven
seasons of shocking deaths
on "Game of Thrones," I still
gasped when Littlefinger died.
Oh, I mean, or he lived?
I should have said
"spoiler alert,"
but if you couldn't guess that
Littlefinger was going to die,
then maybe
"Game of Thrones" isn't for you.
I mean, he had a goatee,
and he talked like this.
[ Droning ] "Lady Sansa.
You can trust me, Lady Sansa."
[ Normal voice ] Now, it might
seem weird to be referencing
"Game of Thrones" now, but there
is a prequel coming out,
and baby Littlefinger is in it.
Littlerfinger.
Anyway, this has been
"The News Is Super Depressing
So Seth Put A Goatee On A Baby."
[ Chime plays ]
The point is, I was still
shocked yesterday
when "Rolling Stone" reported
that Trump kept asking
his advisors if China
was shooting us
with a hurricane gun.
According to "Rolling Stone,"
near the beginning
of Trump's time in office,
he had a pressing question
for his national security aides
and administration officials --
does China have the secret
technology, a weapon even,
to create large man-made
Hurricanes and then launch them
at the United States?
And if so, would this constitute
an act of war
by a foreign power, and could
the U.S. retaliate militarily?
Trump repeatedly asked about
this, according to two former
senior administration officials
and a third person
briefed on the matter.
And this was at the beginning
of his presidency,
and somehow his presidency still
had a middle and an end.
Can you imagine if you went
to Starbucks and ordered
and the barista said, "Uh-huh.
Now, what exactly is coffee?"
And then you went back four
years later,
and that barista was the
manager.
[ Laughter ]
Also, Trump is so [bleep]
crazy that he doesn't just ask,
does China have a hurricane gun.
He's got a bunch of follow-ups,
assuming the answer
is gonna be yes.
[ Laughter ]
How does he even get
to the follow-ups?
"Does China have
a hurricane gun? And if so --"
"Actually, we can just jump
in right now
and save you some time.
They do not have
a hurricane gun."
="Right, but if they did --"
"They don't."
"Sure, but if they were to
develop one --"
"They won't."
It's never just one question.
It's a series of questions.
I imagine him sitting
in a leather chair
with a smoking
jacket in the study,
Sherlock style, pondering the
implications of his discovery.
[ As Sherlock Holmes ]
"Is it possible that China
is using a hurricane gun
to attack us?
If that is the case, would the
use of such a weapon
not constitute an act of war
against a sovereign country?
And if, as international law
stipulates, a sovereign nation
has the right to defend
itself when attacked
by an aggressor nation,
does that not then imply
that the logical response
would be to respond
with a weapon of our own?
Perhaps, and I am merely
brainstorming here,
a tornado cannon."
[ Laughter ]
Maybe this explains
why he was so obsessed
with how much water
there was in Hurricanes.
He thought China was making them
extra wet on purpose.
-This is a tough Hurricane,
one of the wettest
we've ever seen, from the
standpoint of water.
It's tremendously big
and tremendously wet.
-Tremendously big
I think that's playing
at the art house cinema
near my apartment.
[ Laughter ]
It's French, though,
so I'm not sure.
Trump's unhinged conspiracy
theories matter,
because they are the core
of the modern GOP,
a party that has repeatedly said
Trump is their leader,
and if they get their way, will
put Trump back in power in 2024,
either by winning or finishing
off the coup they started
in 2020.
One of our two major political
parties is more concerned
with conspiracy theories
and putting this guy
back in the White House than the
actual crises we're facing
right now,
from impending climate disaster
to the pandemic to massive
wealth inequality,
among many other things.
Senate Republicans
are holding up urgent
COVID relief money,
which could lead to a shortage
of tests and medicine.
And there's even
a baby formula shortage,
due in large part to
monopolistic
control of the market,
and yet shockingly,
several Senators told
"The Huffington Post"
they were unaware
of the crisis on Monday.
I think all these guys
are unaware of the baby formula
shortage 'cause they're,
like, 90 years old.
I guarantee if there was a
Werther's Original shortage,
Charles Grassley would be on the
floor of the Senate every day,
calling on Biden to declare
a national emergency.
They'd immediately pass a bill
100-0 requiring Boeing
and Raytheon to switch from
making planes and missiles
to making hard candy, which,
incidentally,
we could then use
instead of missiles.
There's no Kevlar in the world
that could stop a barrage
of Werther's Originals and
ribbon candy,
which would make a great scene
in an action movie.
"Firing Werther's missiles!
Suck on that!
[ Laughter ]
For a long time."
-♪ Highway to the danger zone ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Double props.
[ Laughter ]
It's got to be really good
for NBC to pay for two props
in "A Closer Look."
They signed off on pipe and then
we said, "We need glasses."
And they're like,
"You've got to choose."
And we're like, "Trust me,
you're gonna want both."
[ Laughter ]
So if senators are too busy
to pass COVID relief
or address climate change
or read up on
a baby formula shortage,
what are they doing?
Well, they're apparently very
concerned about a nationwide
crime spree involving
chalk on sidewalks.
-Messages in support
of abortion rights
are showing up outside the home
of Republican Senator
Susan Collins of Maine.
-Over the weekend, someone used
chalk to write on the sidewalk
outside of the senator's
home in Bangor.
-Maine Authorities say the
Senator called police
after the message was drawn.
It says, "Susie, please
Mainers want WHPA.
Vote yes,
clean up your mess."
-A spokesperson
for Bangor Police says
no crime was committed
because the chalk message
was not threatening.
-That's right.
[ Laughter ]
Susan Collins called the cops
because someone wrote
with chalk on the sidewalk
outside her house.
Does she freak out when there's
a yard sale in her neighborhood?
And the note
wasn't even threatening.
It said please.
Although, I'm not sure how chalk
on a sidewalk
could ever be threatening.
Oh, my God. It must be a note
from the Zodiac Killer.
Fair warning, Detective.
If you step on a crack,
you will break
your mother's back.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Susan Collins claims
she's pro-choice,
but in reality,
she and her fellow Republicans
would much rather spend
their time freaking out
about polite chalk messages
or the identity of the person
who leaked
the Supreme Court opinion
than the actual substance
of what's happening,
that the Supreme Court
is on the verge of erasing
a woman's right
to bodily autonomy,
and that states
are already pushing forward
with severe new restrictions
on reproductive rights,
despite the fact that it seems
very possible
a conservative leaked
the draft opinion
to freeze the majority in place.
Republicans like Texas Senator
Ted Cruz have been insisting
it must be a liberal
in order to shift the story away
from abortion rights
and stay focused on the leak.
Obviously, Cruz doesn't have
any evidence, though.
-There has never been
a leak like this,
and can only, in all likelihood,
have come from a justice
that I think is less likely.
Perhaps one of the clerks,
and the leading --
leading theory
is a conservative cleric
who was afraid
that one of the conservatives
might be persuaded
by Chief Justice Roberts
to join in much
more moderate opinion.
-Do you have the --
Yeah.
-Because I'm not a moron.
Because I live on planet Earth.
-Yeah, you might live here,
but clearly you're
not from here.
I refuse to believe
that voice is actually human.
You sound like
you swallowed a kazoo,
and that beard definitely
looks like a disguise
you'd see in "Men in Black."
I'm -- I'm simply asking why
the Biden administration
refuses to do anything about
the rising price of sugar water.
So, we don't know
who the leaker is.
[ Coughs ] Ginni Thomas.
[ Coughs ] But Republicans would
much rather focus on the leak
than the substance of the bill
they blocked today
because preserving Roe v. Wade
is massively popular.
In fact, they're so desperate
to distract from the fallout
of what the Supreme Court
is about to do
that Cruz went on Fox News this
week to claim ludicrously
that protests against
the Supreme Court's action
were somehow worse
than the violent coup attempt
Trump and Cruz
fomented on January 6th.
-On January 6, 2021,
you had tens of thousands
of people peacefully protesting,
and yet the corporate media
and Democrats slander them
with the made up term
insurrectionist.
And yet, in this instance,
they are not willing to
call off their goons.
Yeah. Why is the corporate
Democratic media
slandering all those patriots
who peacefully smashed windows
and stormed the Capitol
but refusing
to crack down on the thugs
and goons who are violently
writing coded messages in chalk?
Has the world
turned right side up?
By the way, Ted Cruz knows
what he's doing here.
He originally called
the insurrection
a violent terrorist attack,
but then the extreme
pro-insurrection wing
of his party,
led by guys like Tucker Carlson,
got mad at him
so he had to reverse himself
and go on Fox News
to grovel for forgiveness.
And now to please Trump
and the MAGA base,
he's doubling down on calling
January 6th a peaceful protest.
Next, he's going to claim
he was just flying to Cancun
to escape the hurricane gun.
They had it aimed
right at Texas,
but thankfully we were able
to neutralize it
with President Trump's
hurricane wall
made out of Werther's.
You can't get through it.
You can't get through
a Werther's wall.
We're facing a series
of major crises,
from the rising cost of living,
to extreme wealth inequality,
to impending climate disaster,
to a deadly respiratory disease
that's still spreading
to a Supreme Court
that's poised to erase
reproductive rights
and the bodily autonomy
of tens of millions of women.
And yet Republicans would rather
whine and throw tantrums
about leaks and sidewalk chalk.
These people talk about leaks
so much,
you think their pants were...
-Tremendously wet.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's been "A Closer Look," baby.
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over
two million meals a year to men,
women and children
living with HIV, AIDS,
cancer and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help.
Now more than ever,
if you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.